you got this idea to be a
uh like a dj like a bar mitzvah dj
wedding dj sweet 16 dj right you play
records and what like well i yeah i had
it started first where there was this
bar in kansas city
called
studebakers yeah it was it was like a
50s bar right and uh i was trying to
find a job waiting tables but i had
really long hair right i was probably
about i don't know 18 and i didn't want
to cut my hair
and uh and so i went in and they said uh
you know i was looking for this like a
job as a waiter a bar back and uh they
weren't hiring i said what about djs
because i saw they had a dj booth they
go well actually yeah and then they
would do these things called show times
where every hour he had to stand on the
bar and do like hand jive like one of
those cheese ball kinds of things
but i wound up auditioning to dj
did you know anything about music i mean
did you know what to play
i knew like 50 some 50s music yeah i had
i mean i had a pretty good idea of the
music to play but because you got to get
people up and dancing isn't that your
job yeah but this was a bar that
thankfully i uh i didn't have to do try
and get people up and dancing so much at
this kind of place right but i wound up
having to wear like a 50s pompadour wig
because i wouldn't cut my hair and they
wanted me to look it was just so it must
have looked really cool but it's really
cool like an elvish wig like an elvis
wig
but then when i moved from kansas
because i was in kansas when i moved to
go to acting school i needed a job on
the weekends and so i thought all right
you know what i have dj experience right
so then i got hired with a company that
would do like weddings and bar mitzvahs
and things like that so that you were
the guy you were the wedding and uh yeah
for about a year wow and uh i guess i
guess that teaches you something it's
better than i guess being a waiter and
having to earn a living while you go to
doctor i did that i did that performing
but i mean yeah yeah but it was also it
was also a real uh
i mean what where was what was your
character named donnie the dweeb or
something well i had to you know it was
a job that i didn't really i didn't love
it that much and i always felt a little
bit like
god i got a bit of a douche i'm like
trying to get these kids out on the
floor and yes that was where i got to
keep the party going yeah and then it
was and then i remember about
i had two bar mitzvahs in one day
and it was on the second bar mitzvah
hour 18 or whatever and i lost i just
lost it and i was dancing with these
kids and i started dancing just like a
you know like a freak uh and mocking the
entire thing but they thought the kids i
was funny you know so they kind of
cleared the dance floor a little bit and
my boss got on the mic and said hey it's
donnie dweeb
and that became you and then i was like
oh god
i can't bail on this so i have to do it
oh no and then the following week there
was like another bar mitzvah and these
kids said hey are you the guy that does
the dork dance
it became my thing that i hated to do
but then i would get requests and if i
got a request to dj a party i'd get an
extra 100 bucks